[Music]
This is uh the API key. So, if you
haven't scanned this already, please
scan it. Um it'll take you to our cloud
where you can sign up for a free API
key. This will be the only thing you
kind of need to do the workshop today.
Everyone got a picture? Everyone good?
Cool.
Okay. Um hello everyone. Uh we are very
excited to see you here. Today we
organized a very fun workshop for all of
you. Uh we're going to first start with
explanation of what mixture of experts
is and what like why this architecture
matters and then we're going to use
agents to create something very similar
to it but it's called mixture of agents.
So you replace your experts with real
agents. Um there will be a code alone
session so everyone will build their own
app at the end
and um for the agenda first of all we're
going to introduce the concept what is
the mixture of experts why this
architecture exists and what kind of
models are using it um and uh this is
basically like the way for us to
continue improving the models that we
build u so like child GPT think about
that models how do we scale them further
so they become smarter more in
intelligent and there are two ways to do
it so one is to pre-train from scratch
with mixture of experts architecture.
Another way is building a mixture of
agents. So when you combine already
pre-trained model together in a one
complex architecture so we're going to
build exactly approach number two and a
hands-on workshop and uh at the end we
will have Q&A. So if you guys are
interested about this models, what we do
with this models at Cerebras or you have
any other questions we can answer that.
Um yeah, a little bit about me. So I'm a
head research scientist at Cerebras. I
worked there for almost 4.5 years. Um I
am specifically focused at researching
mixture of experts architectures and um
just other architectures that help us
improve the LLMs and make the training
more hardware efficient. Um in the past
I spent some time working on data
scaling. So I created a data set called
slim pajama. Um that data set was the
largest the best in quality data set
when it was released. Um, and yeah,
prior to Cerebras, I was at Google
working on research and engineering
projects.
Perfect. Hi, my name is Daniel. I'm the
head of growth here at Cerebras. I do
both developer activations, developer
marketing, but I also do startup sales.
So, if you need tokens and you're trying
to run your startup and you want to use
Cerebris in production after the
workshop, come talk to me. I am the
token the token arbiter for Cerebras for
everyone that is not enterprise. Um and
if you have a cool research project you
want to use Cerebras for I am also the
person to talk to. So if you want tokens
for your project talk to me. I also
really like Hopot. Um I had Hopot three
times in the last week. Um so yeah
that's that's a little bit about me. I'm
based in San Francisco and I do a lot of
these types of workshops and events and
things like that. Um and here's my
Twitter uh if you guys want to follow
me. Um, and this is our intern, Kevin.
Uh, he's not here with us because he's
taking his last high school final. He's
in high school, but I wanted to put him
here because he's the uh person that
built 99% of the workshop that you're
going to be doing here today, and I
wanted to make sure we shouted him out.
Wait, I want to take a selfie with him.
I wanted to show him cuz he doesn't know
I'm doing this. Okay. Um, and yeah, he's
uh going to school in UCLA coming in the
fall, but he's currently in high school.
So, yeah. And that's his Twitter if you
guys want to follow him.
Great. Before we get started, who here
has heard of Cerebrris?
Okay, pretty good. Last time I asked
this question like eight months ago, the
there was like two hands in a room full
of like this. So, it's so much progress
that we've made in the couple last
couple months. So, I will dive a little
bit deeper into what Cerebrris and why
our hardware is so much superior than
our competitors in the later part of our
presentation. But quickly, Cerebrris is
a hardware company that makes custom
silicon that uh runs AI models super
duper fast. And here's a sidebyside of
the chips uh comparing us to an Nvidia
H100. So there's just a sizable
difference here. and um things that make
our hardware architecture super dominant
kind of like all boils down to the
innovations we have made in the hardware
itself and how we're able to linearly
scale with larger models which I'll get
into later but currently we hold the
world record in every single model we
host publicly um and it's not even
close. So for Llama 3.370B we're around
15.5 times faster than the fastest
inference provider on a GPU. So if you
want kind of like something that doesn't
compare to anything that's currently in
the market, Sirius is kind of your only
option for fast inference. So that's
what our company does and this is what
I'm bringing to startup. So if you're a
startup that wants this inference, you
should come talk to me after the talk.
So what are we doing today? Yeah. So
actually spoiler alert, we're going to
use Cerebras hardware today for our uh
workshop. So if you you guys can um
actually try it. But uh before I want to
explain what we're actually building.
So, we're going to build um an
application with a mixture of agents. Um
each agent will be a separate LLM. Um
and kind of like right now, I want to
explain why this is beneficial, why we
want to build that. Um and why this
architecture is better compared to like
a monolithic one LLM that we use right
now. Uh thank you. Yeah. So, um sort of
like from like pretraining perspective,
how do we make larger models more
intelligent, better, how do we scale
them faster? So all of these type of
questions we ask at Cerebras uh when we
have our hardware we can scale models
pretty fast but like how do we make them
more efficient what kind of
architectures we need to invest in. So
um I kind of wanted to give sort of like
the evolution that happened in the lamp
space for you guys. So we started with
the GPT3 that was released a few years
ago and the model there um was quite
small um and basically what GPD3 paper
showed is that if you continue scaling
the model size you're going to improve
the performance your models will have
better skill sets. That's how you're
going to scale it. Um the the next thing
that we saw in the LM evolution is you
actually have to spend a lot of time
improving your data that you train on.
So, llama model uh became bigger but it
also spend a lot of time on curating the
data set and scaling the the the number
of uh talkings you train for as well.
And now u you guys probably heard about
DeepC3 that was released a few months
ago. That model took some additional
innovations into place. So if you want
to go even larger you see like GPT3 is
13 billion, Llama 3 is 400 billion and
deepse 3 is 600 billion. So if you want
to continue scaling the model size which
is what gives us better models we need
to come up with not just data set
improvements but also architecture
improvements.
So how do we actually um improve the
models and thus like serve the large
models because as you increase the
number of parameters you have to come up
with a like a way to scale it to scale
your inference infrastructure and make
it more efficient. Uh the answer here is
mixture of experts. Um and these type of
models like to just give you like an
overview how it works. Imagine that you
have a transformer architecture which is
what we use as a backbone for large
language models. It has different types
of layers. So here I highlighted like
there are more layers there but like one
important layer some important layers
are embedding attention at feed forward
layers. They all have different types of
purposes in the network. Um and now
we're gonna see like how uh we change
the standard transformer bottle
transformer architecture into something
called mixture of experts. So if you
look at different layers and you do some
interpretability work, you will figure
out that uh feed forward network has a
specific bottleneck. It has a challenge
because fit forward network sort of like
has to disentangle all the information
that um previous layers uh process like
attention layer. So you can think about
it this way. um fit forward network has
to decide which neuron in the network to
activate when it sees a golden gate
bridge in a text. So it's really hard
because the task that we have for LMS
sometimes they have different languages
sometime sometimes they require
different specialization they could be
like mod domain biology etc. So feed
forward network has the hardest job in
in the whole um so how does mixture of
experts solve this bottleneck? Um
instead of having one monolithic fit
forward network, we will create separate
fit forward networks and we will call
them experts as you can see on the right
side of the screen. Um each expert will
be specialized in a specific task. So
you can think about this way one expert
can be solving math problems. Another
expert can be a biology teacher. Right?
And the other thing that is crucial here
this this type of architecture allows us
to increase parameters of the model. you
create multiple copies of the feed
format network but you don't have to
activate all of them for every token you
route through the network you can see
that there is an additional network
called router within our network which
basically decides which expert to select
for a particular token so you can click
next yeah and that allows us to actually
increase the width of the model increase
the capacity of the model uh and scale
the parameters because we know that from
parameters you are getting better skills
without increasing the inference time.
So you can actually activate same number
of parameters as for the monolithic
model. So you will might map like in
terms of the time but you will be better
in quality because you trained a larger
model.
Um yeah so um sort of like to clause on
on this um this is um the approach that
other u companies are using like this is
the industry standard right now open AAI
GPT4 models entropic all of them are
using this way um this approach to scale
the models um and to gain better skills
uh for for their models.
So yeah, models are really really cool
and they are kind of like becoming the
industry standard for being able to run
large large parameter models in a
efficient way. So you don't have to
continuously just add hardware to be
able to run better and better quality
models. But there are some other
approaches that also work. So something
I want to talk a little bit about is
inference time compute. Um last year I
believe um Elia Ciscover uh gave a talk
at Europe's around how it is we're in
the age of inference time compute where
we have just thrown as much data as
possible when we pre-train these really
really large models and eventually we're
going to hit a data wall right where we
have no more additional unique data to
train our models with. So now what we
can do is do more compute after the
model has been trained to be able to get
better and better results and more and
more intelligent models.
So an example of um problems that
benchmarks test for are math problems.
So I want to first take a um math
problem from the Amy math competition um
and see how certain um models kind of
tackle this kind of problem. And the
thing with these types of math problems
is that it's harder for like a single
non-reasoning model to be able to solve
these because they require multiple
steps in sequential thought where it's
really hard to do things like this
without reasoning. And when I ran this
exact problem through GPT40, which is
not a reasoning model, it took 45
seconds to come to the wrong answer. And
this is like the frontier model. But uh
chat GPT03 um sorry GPT03 which is a
reasoning model took 293 seconds to come
up with the right answer. So this is it
on the right on do doing everything
correctly but it just took 293 seconds.
So if you want something in a reasonable
within three business days kind of
timeline this is like this is probably
not the solution for you. Like imagine
you're like do scrolling through an app
and it just is loading for six minute or
three minutes or how four minutes and 53
seconds. that just like an unreasonable
amount of time for a lot of like tasks.
So I want to introduce something called
mixture of agent which is leveraging the
collective intelligence of multiple LLMs
to come to the right answer and that I I
think like because cerebrros is a super
fast inference provider. I'm sure
everyone can see where this is going. So
a mixture of agents is basically the
ability to take advantage of these
earthshattering speeds from our hardware
and apply them into harder problems like
this. So it's not just about speed. It's
about getting higher intelligence with
less smart models.
And mixture of agents is a lot of it is
inspired by mixture of experts
architecture because essentially you're
trying to do the same thing. You're
trying to squeeze out as much
intelligence in an efficient way from a
lot of like uh a lot of like kind of
tokens whether it's within the model or
outside of the model. So the basically
how it works is that you send inputs to
multiple LLMs with custom system prompts
like agents and then each model gives
its own response and then basically a
final model combines all of the answers
from all the individual models into a
single answer and this has shown that it
outperforms even frontier models on
certain uh benchmarks um as benchmarked
by together AI which who's the ones that
kind of came up with this idea and this
term.
Um, so I want to show you an example of
a startup that's actually building in
production with Cerebras in this mixture
of agents model.
There's a YouTube video. Let's let's
see. Worst case, I can just show the
Google Drive link.
Sorry, the internet, as you all know, is
not great. So,
I hope this loads. If not, wait. I think
I have it locally saved. One second. Uh,
oh yeah, I do have it locally saved.
Perfect. So this is uh ninjate uh.ai and
you can try this product in production
right now and they're basically building
a smarter uh like chat chatbot and this
is ninjate solving the same exact
question in 7.4 seconds and getting the
answer correct. So people are using this
type of technique and our inference
together in production to solve really
hard questions like this math problem.
Cool.
Okay, hopefully
please please tech gods. Okay, cool. So,
we uh basically with uh what this
startup did was take um a bunch of
models and a bunch of LLM calls and get
the right answer that a frontier model
reasoning model took 293 seconds all the
way down to seven seconds. And here's
how their whole application works. So
they have a planning agent that spits
out eight potential proposals for the
right answer.
And then another token, a critique agent
comes in and be like, "Hey, are these
any of them feasible answers to this
particular problem that I'm trying to
solve." In this case, all of them were
bad. So then what happens is that the
planning agent goes back to the drawing
board and then spits out 16k context
worth of thinking tokens of eight answer
proposals and then the same virtual
cycle happens where the critique agents
like are any of them good in this case
uh in the example I showed before two of
them were potential answer candidates
that could have been the correct answer
and then another agent a summarization
agent takes those two top answers and
then turns them in to the final answer
which is eventually the right answer. So
this whole process, even though it took
7 seconds, took over 500,000 tokens to
be generated and 32 LLM calls, some of
them in parallel, some of them
sequential. So this type of system
allows you to take advantage of
non-frontier models, even open source
models that may not perform as well on
benchmarks, and turn them into
performing better than frontier models.
So yeah, like I said again, why don't
people use 03 in production? It's
because it's very slow. Like what I
can't even think about like use cases
where you can wait five minutes to come
up with an answer unless it's like very
asynchronous.
And Cerebras solves the speed
bottleneck. Um and obviously Cerebras is
the leader in fast inference. So I want
to show you why we are so fast. So this
is an architecture diagram of a GPU and
highlighted in red is the core or the
thing that does all the mathematical
computations that allow LMS to predict
the next token. In this particular GPU
which is the H100 there around 17,000
cores on this chip.
The problem is that the memory where all
the weights and all the uh intermediate
calculations and all the other
information needed to produce the next
token is stored largely off the chip.
And these memory channels that
communicate between the cores and the
external memory become bottlenecks as
you run larger and larger models because
of course you have to transfer in more
weights and you have to transfer in more
intermediate calculations in the KV
cache while you're trying to calculate
the next token.
Cerebras tackles this by having a
radically different memory management
system. We have 900,000 individual cores
on one chip. And then with those 900,000
cores, we have 900,000 individual memory
stores that are distributed all across
the chip one to one with our compute
cores. And each core has direct access
to memory.
The core specific memory holds the same
set of weights regardless of what you're
putting into the system. So basically,
you don't need to wait for the external
weights or the intermediate calculations
to load to be able to do the
computations. we can just do it in real
time because there's no kind of memory
transfer time that you need to wait for.
Everything is just on the chip
and cerebr scales linearly across larger
models. The thing that makes service
really fast with super large models is
that the only piece of data that's being
transferred from chip to chip is
activations. That's the only piece of
data that travels. It can even be like
transferred using a single Ethernet
cord. that amount of data it's very
small with a DGX cluster with multiple
GPUs they have to transfer so many
activations and cache computations in
between layers because single GPUs
cannot do multiple layers of
computations via hundreds of MVL links
connectors switches etc and that
networking piece is the reason why we're
so dominant compared to Nvidia GPUs
so Daria how does this all translate
Sure yeah um I probably want to start
with like a problem that I have and see
how many people have the same problem.
So when I interact with a monolithic
model with just one model, I usually ask
to solve a particular problem and then
it doesn't get the right solution right
away usually if the problem is complex,
right? So I have to continue prompting
it and refining it and at some point
hitting the number of tokens that the
model can process or something like that
and start over the chat from scratch.
Does anyone else have the same problem?
Okay, cool. So I'm not alone here. Uh
what we do uh with mixture of agents,
we're going to specialize each agent to
solve a particular portion of the
problem. So imagine you have a very
complex problem. Um I don't know, you
need to do a surgery, let's say, right?
Imagine that. So we need different types
of people to help with the surgery and
we're going to ask each expert to
specialize in one specific part of the
surgery. So they all together can work
and produce like a better result
compared to just one person who can do a
surgery, right? So we're going to do it
through prompt engineering. Um and the
the one nice thing about it is instead
of doing multiple rounds, multiple
iterations to find the best solution at
the end, you're going to find the
solution at the zero shot. So at one
shot, you're going to ask one question
and because each kind of like agent is
already specialized in solving a
particular portion of the task, they
will they will combine the result
together and it's going to be the final
solution without continuous prompting.
So this is what we're going to build
today. So this is the time for the
hands-on workshop. So before we move on,
this is like the second time I'm showing
this. Everyone needs an API key. This is
like the one thing you need to do for
the workshop. So everyone get an API
key. Okay, cool. And then you uh please
uh go to this GitHub link um and then
start and fork the repo. That's um the
next step. Kevin created it. Kevin, not
Daniel. Kevin. But I don't have uh HD
shots of Kevin going like this. So uh
that's me. Yeah,
this is also in our Slack channel if you
don't want to QR code scan. So if you
are in the AI engineer Slack channel,
feel free to go to um yeah, we also
dropped the slides there and uh you guys
can interact there if you want help each
other out. It's called MOA
MOA workshop. Does anyone have issues
finding that? Let us know.
Yeah. And once you guys uh start and
fork the repo, um we're going to deploy
this app via Streamlit or you can run it
locally, whatever you prefer. Um I just
don't want to deal with Python
installation issues. So that's why we're
I I suggest if you have the internet
bandwidth to go through Streamlit, but
if not, doing it locally via um Python
is fine. And just quickly, u Daniel is
going through the slides, but if you
want to come back to some of the steps,
we shared it in a slack channel. So you
can open slides 50 to 54. They will have
the same instructions.
Um MOA, mixture of agents uh-
workshop.
Yeah. So once you star and fork the repo
uh you basically are going to deploy it
via streamllet um or locally um and
basically how you deploy it on
streamllet is you go to streamlink.io. I
would suggest logging in with GitHub
that way everything is set up for you um
and then deploy the server workshop that
you have forked into your GitHub repo
changing the main file path and then
clicking advanced settings. And once you
click advanced settings um you have you
just plug in your Cerebrus API key here
and that's how you run the app.
So I'll uh wait like uh like two let's
say three minutes for everyone to go and
clone and um spin up their um app and
then we can go from there. Uh raise your
hand if you need help from me or Daria.
We can help you get set up if you have
any questions.
Let me set a timer. If you guys want to
have an access to the presentation, here
is the QR code to our Slack channel
called MOA workshop. And if you want
steps on how to set up the uh everything
with the streamllet, you can go to the
slide 50 to 54. I already shared it in
the chat there.
Yeah, I think Kevin the API key.
Kevin committed the API key. God damn
it.
Thank you so much for bringing that up.
It's okay. His API key is rate limited.
It's not like he has like the god API
key. But it's okay. He's an intern,
right? Like yeah, feel free to like use
your own though, please. That would be
great because that will get rate
limited. If everyone uses it, it's going
to like obviously get very limited.
Daniel, I think I'm glad that my boss is
not here. Yeah,
the secret just stays between you, us,
and the internet, you know, cuz
apparently this getting in is being It's
being recorded. No, I know. I know. I'm
going to rotate it right now.
Perfect.
Danielle, I think we are getting the
prize for the funniest workshop ever,
right? Wait, really? Yeah, probably.
Right. API key is committed. I kind of
want to win though. So, like um if
everyone wants to vote for us as like
the most popular slashf funnest
workshop, you know, I wouldn't say no.
You know,
huh.
Oh, it's a bribery thing. Okay. I see. I
see. There are strings attached to this
vote. I see. I see.
Yeah. Yeah, let us know if you have any
trouble spinning up the workshop and
then using definitely your own API key.
Um,
[Laughter]
okay.
Do we have a slide how the um workshop
page front page should look like? Yeah.
Wait, what? Sorry.
So I read
what next? Oh no, you you uh it's in the
read me. It's basically you have to
install like all the requirements file
and then you run one command.
It's very simple. We made it we try to
make it as simple as possible. Thank you
timer. So oh yeah when when you have it
all run running it should look like
something like this. I would say very
sexy UI you know.
So, um, we wanted you to really
experience what MOA systems look like
because I feel like this is a very new
concept and it's a great way, this kind
of app that Kevin built is a great way
for you to get started with what the
possibilities are with MOA systems maybe
in production. So, um, basically how
this UI works is that in the top you
configure your summarization agent.
Basically, the thing that summarizes all
the things and actually like aggregates
all the individual results from your
individual agents into one. Um, we have
a very basic system prompt here. You can
change it if you want. And then under
agent management, we have individual
agents that you can create with custom
prompts. And you here you can adjust
things like the temperature, the model
as well as the specific prompt that you
want to put in the agent and also rename
it, you know, to something fun. Um, and
here you can delete agents or you can
create new ones. You can have more than
three and you can also have different
layers. You can have multiple like uh
iterations of how many times you want
them to go through the solution. And
basically the first part is not
competitive. It's just going to be us
all having fun, right? So, it's gonna I
can ask a question here like plan a trip
to San Francisco for me and my friend
Daria
from
from 3 p.m. to 9:00 p.m. and then see
and then what it's doing is behind the
scenes it's basically spawning all of
the individual agents and then going
through multiple layers of calculations
for it to return the final answer.
Here we have three layers with multiple
LLM calls. So it might take a little bit
of time. It's just the Wi-Fi. Oh, it's
probably the Wi-Fi actually.
Can you zoom in? Oh, yeah.
And if anyone doesn't see a screen like
this, could you guys let me know and I
can come and help you with any steps.
Wow, the Wi-Fi is really bad.
Does anyone not have the screen?
You don't? Yeah. So, um,
okay. Maybe I can just like walk you
through what what we see right now on
the screen. Um there are multiple layers
that we created. Each layer is basically
a set of models and they are connected
together. Layer is a sequential but at
each layer models are process in
parallel. So once we get the output from
layer one they will it will be combined
together as an input for layer two and
then after the layer three there is this
like final model that we call
summarization model that will process
the final output combining the results
from uh previous layers.
So all of these tokens were generated
sacrificed
for for the final answer. So all of
these tokens basically allow you to
cover more surface area and have a more
comprehensive answer. So all of this was
generated
through all the other models.
Yes.
So each layer has a set of agents that
operate together. Their output is
finalized after that layer. So you can
think about it's concatenated and used
as an input to the next layer.
Was everyone able to ask a very fun
personal question to the MOA chat?
Anyone struggling with that? Happy to
help.
Okay, great. So now comes the actual
competitive fun part of the uh of the
workshop. This is all fun in games until
comes the competition. So, uh then go
and select the AI configur AI
configuration challenge.
And basically your job is to come up
with the perfect MOA system to generate.
Okay, perfect code is a little extra.
Maybe it's like really good code. Really
good code. We believe in you. Um so
instead of writing code yourself, you'll
become an AI prompt engineer and system
architect. And your goal is to configure
your AI agent like mixture of agents
system to automatically generate code
that scores the maximum 120 points in
our automated grader. And basically uh
to participate you just have to go into
configure AI and generate. So here you
can select so I can actually just do it
with you for the first one. So here it
has some very awesome preset responses.
So let me so see you can like set some
awesome presets that our intern created
and then we can generate the code.
Hopefully the Wi-Fi is good. Okay, the
code has been generated. So here the
code has been generated and we can
submit the solution. And here the
baseline is already designed with the
prompt, the preset prompts to be at like
C and your job is to be an A student
because we're all overachievers in this
room. So basically, you can now change
things like the prompt itself or the
model. So let's like set it to the Quen
model and then see what happens. So we
can generate the code again
and then submit the solution for
grading. And here it's scored slightly
better. So we went from a C to a B be B.
It's a solid B with literally just by
changing the model model like the the
model that it uses for the main agent.
So your job for the rest of this
workshop is to figure out first what is
the right combination of the main model
the number of cycles like how many
layers you want the temperature as well
as the system prompt for the main prompt
and as well as the individual layers
that will uh that will spawn for every
single iteration. So here you can select
different models different particular
prompts and then use that to come up
with the right answer. And I believe
Daria and our intern both got perfect
scores. So you're shooting for perfect
scores for your mixture of agent system.
Do we do we have a function somewhere
that we given them? Wait, like the
actual Python function that has uh bugs
in it. Uh no, that gets um inputed
through here. So you can just like
change this. But um how do they where do
they find the function? Oh, they don't
they kind of optimize it. Oh, it's right
here.
A default challenge. Where is the
function itself? like the Python
function.
[Music]
No, it's the function. This is the
function. Where is the implementation of
the function that we give them as a
baseline? Oh, we don't it the the the we
changed this. So the challenge is like
generates the Python function from
scratch. Okay. Okay. Gotcha. Okay. So
that's is important to say like let's
come back to that and set up the
challenge, right? Because we have
engineers who know how to write Python.
Um so the challenge is here we want to
create a function that's called
calculate user matrix and the purpose is
basically to calculate the matrix right
we have some details here what the
function is supposed to um output given
an input yeah so this is the the test
that is used when you click grading this
is like the the the input to your AI
agent system
this is the input that will go in and
then basically um
okay I'm going to send them the baseline
function Okay, so imagine this like you
have an interview um let's say a tech
company right and at the interview they
can ask you to optimize a function for
us today's Python function this Python
function has some bugs and it's also not
optimized so we want from you is using
LLMs basically find the solution that
fixes all the bugs and optimizes it to
the level that you get the maximum score
we created the grader that basically
will use um like LLM generated function
um as as an input and it will give you a
score and an idea is to get 120 out of
120. Um you can see we already created
some specific agents to help you solve
this task in one shot. One agent is
working with bugs. Um it basically tries
to find all the bugs and edge cases. One
agent is working with um performance
performance. So it's going to optimize
it. You don't you don't like recomputee
some stuff. Um and the last one is what
is it? Just like overall. Oh, just
overall. Yeah. So, like the final the
final like model um the way it can work,
you can ask it to look at the outputs
from like three or whatever number of
agents you created at previous layer and
kind of create a final function using
the inputs from different um agents and
I'm going to send you the uh Python
function in the Slack channel. So, if
you guys see some errors yourself like
engineers, right, you can actually
configure the prompts this way. You can
ask one agent to like, oh, I see that
there is an empty list that we try to
like access by index, right? Could you
please fix that? And that agent will
work on that specific problem. Um, or
you can also see what the default config
outputs and and figure out like what are
the remaining issues in the Python
function. So, it's sort of like vibe
coding but with with your brains, right?
Um, isn't that vibe coding? Don't you v
code with your brain? I've seen I've
seen multiple Do you turn off your brain
when you v code? It just like you really
let the computer take over, huh?
Oh, it's this is should be default. Like
this is literally I just All I did was
spun up the Streamlit app. Like are you
not seeing it? Oh, no. You have to go to
the Okay, you have to Sorry. Can you
scroll up here?
And there will be a prize for whoever
gets the highest score. Actually, have I
thought about what the prize will be?
Not yet. So, I'll take suggestions from
the winner.
Sorry, I don't know how to respond to
that. I'm I'm like erroring out right
now.
Not the lowest score. That's so cool.
It's actually quite good. If they can
get zero, it means they can get maximum
two. Oh, really? Yeah. If you get like
low zero, let us know. Wait, if to get
zero, can't you just edit the thing to
be like just return nothing? Isn't that
wouldn't that be zero or be like write a
write a rust function and the greater
will be like it's rust
don't give them ideas oh okay okay sorry
but yeah if someone is really interested
in getting maximum score and you need
hints try it yourself though but like if
you need hints we're happy to give
yourself oh yeah we can do hints I guess
you
hits the max score or zero. Please let
us know. Not the zero, Daria. I want to
see the person who gets zero. Not the
zero, Daria. Not the zero.
Sorry, what' you say?
No, it's the perfect score. There was
like three people that got it. My
invitation. It's on. Okay, everyone.
Okay. Can you raise your hand if you got
the 120 perfect score?
Okay, everyone. Congratulations. Wow, we
got hella winners. Okay.
Um, after the Q&A, please come up to us
so I can get your email and then I can
get you something fun. I don't know what
it will be. So, please when you come up
to me, come with suggestions of what you
want, but like let's keep it realistic.
No Teslas, no no like no large gifts
like that. Okay? Like, uh, so something
fun.
Huh?
I don't know about that one. Okay. Um,
before we keep you all keep going
because I feel like a lot of people got
the challenge. So, great job you guys.
Um, I want to do a quick Q&A with me and
Daria. So, if you don't mind, if you can
come up with one of those, if you have
questions for us about anything Cerebrus
related or mixture of agents or mixture
of experts, come ask us questions right
now, please. Wait, can you come up to
the mic? I'm so sorry for you to do
this, but apparently like that's how we
get content.
Um, do you guys like
this? Can you can you come to the mic?
I'm so sorry. You have to do cardio.
How do you Yeah, if you guys can like
hit the mic. How do you How do you
autoML this stuff? AutoML the stuff.
Yeah. Okay. So, I mean, it's all fun and
all to go manually and figure out the
prompts. What if the problem's slightly
harder where it would take you 100 hours
or a thousand hours to figure out the
prompts and you said, "I want to throw a
solution to solve this."
That's my question. I mean I feel like
in the application it's going to happen,
right? So I don't I mean it's already
happening if you look at like um like
Devon for example, right? Like the
codegen startup you ask it to do
something and like a couple hours later
it comes back to you with like a
proposed solution, right? And then
tackling beyond just like fix a snippet
of code. It's just building whole new
systems or whole new application. So
that kind of thing is already happening.
It's all about like how can Cerebras as
a company that builds custom hardware,
how can we enable those people? So
instead of taking hours, it takes
minutes. So it's I don't think it's the
technology that's not there yet. It's
about like how do we make it usable in
the current like landscape that doesn't
take that's not so painful. So I think
it's like actually it's already
happening like to to to apply AI towards
these really hard multi-our problems.
This is kind of a smallcale simulation
of what you could do with a lot faster
inference to speed that up.
What regions are your is your hardware
company running in and do you have plans
for uh global distribution? Yeah, so
right now we opened I think uh six data
centers in the US in the last year and
we are opening one in France this year
and then we are currently have plans for
one in Canada as well and we only expect
that to go more global as the time goes
on. And one more, how how long does it
take you to onboard a new model when a a
new model is released or a new version
of a model? That's a great question. I
think it depends on the model. So the
the blocker for us to onboard a new
model is if we have all the kernels that
are written to make sure that it
supports the new model and in some cases
like Quen 32B that you all have access
to that took very little time because
that architecture was very similar to
Llama architecture in terms of the
kernels needed to run it and we had all
the available kernels. So all it took
was all a bunch of QAing and like
implementing API level features to get
that to work on our system. On the other
hand, there are other models um that are
extremely hard because we don't have the
right kernels ready yet to support that
model at in an efficient way. So that
takes more time because the kernel
engineering team needs to write the
custom kernels needed for that model. So
it really depends on the model
architecture. Thanks.
Got a question about um power
consumption. So
this sort of new
architecture is going to take shorter
amount of time but what about a power
consumption like are we talking about
similar to what Nvidia is doing or is it
more is it less yeah that's a great
question and I think it's not a onetoone
right because we have a just a
completely different chip architecture
so it really depends on the workload but
uh we've observed and this is what we
put in our website that it's around a
third of the power consumption of Nvidia
GPUs for the equivalent ent workload.
It's just that our chips are a lot more
massive. So, it has a lot more
throughput and a lot more like it can
just take in a lot and generate more um
and and it takes a significant number of
chips, Nvidia chips to match like what
one system can do. So, it's not an
apples to apples, but like I think uh we
are a lot more power efficient in most
use cases.
That's a great question. It is. I do get
that question also. So, it's a very
commonly asked question. And I think
everyone's like, how does this big chip
take in energy? Okay, what's up? Uh my
question is about a mixture of uh agents
when I compare with um I don't know like
um the soda models, you know, like um
benchmarks wise where I I should put it.
I think it's like about the
configuration of the MOA agent. And I
think that's where things get a little
bit tricky. It's like if you have really
shitty prompts for your MOA system, it's
going to perform shittily, right? So,
it's about like it's like tuning all of
the prompts in your MOA system and then
it will perform better in the benchmark.
So, you actually do need to put in it's
not like an out ofthe-box thing, right?
Because it's not training. It's like
optimizing the system for your use case.
So you need to make sure that you put in
the engineering work needed to optimize
all of the whole system whether it's
like using the right models or is it
writing the like all of the combination
of the things need to work out for it to
be better. The whole point though is
that it can be better. It's just that
you have to like actually like engineer
it to be better. One thing like from the
theory perspective if you have like if
you have an idea of like what's the
ensol learning case where you create
like multiple models they communicate
between each other and like together
ensol basically provides a more robust a
better solution than just one model. So
this is inspired by that by like you
know like decision trees or like you
know when we created like standard ML
models we always get like more less less
I guess like memorized solution uh more
generalized from multiple models. So in
theory, even if you configure each model
the same way and create the same prompt,
the final answer can be better than just
one model. Yeah. Yeah. Like a X boost
got to my mind when I saw that that kind
of approach, right? like you have
multiple like a swarm of decisions and
then you can get like um
I I guess what I'm trying to get at is
maybe there is a tradeoffs when you have
like too many um trees or agents
like um maybe like uh if the question
that you need is too of
can it like like can it like create
worse solution if you create too many
agents
I I guess if there is a danger of being
more like a homogeneous dancer if you
have a too many Asians
because maybe you have like a single
Asian that gets get right but you have
like 2,000 agents that get it wrong.
Yeah, this is a very good question and
so for like mixture of experts when we
create different experts we also think
about it this way like how many agent
how many experts you want to have. So
then they're all kind of like used in
the network. So here what's likely going
to happen if you create too many agents
not all of them are going to be used. So
you will create like redundancy in the
network and you will just spend more
time like getting the output from like
ex like agents here and they're not
going to be used in the final solution
if that makes sense. Yeah. Yeah. I feel
like like feature importance in a boost,
right? Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. Cool. I got
it. Thank you. Yeah. Hi. Uh do you all
support like bringing your own
fine-tuned model? uh like let's say if
it's fine tuned on like quen 32 billion
itself uh which you already support. We
do for enterprise clients. I know that's
not the answer anyone wants to hear but
right now we are working on supporting
Laura fine-tuned models that's in the
road map but it's not currently
supported but if you're an enterprise
customer that's looking to on board uh
custom models we do have a number of
customers uh running fine-tuned models
in our cloud.
Hello. Yes, a short question. Uh, did
you already try it diffusion text
generation models? Like they 10 time
faster than simple LLMs and they may
have super different architecture and
how it fits your approaches and course.
I'm curious are you working on diffusion
models yourself? Uh no not no we mostly
trying to use it on board it from
pragmatic perspective and they already
really fast and probably with uh with
your approach it will be much faster
like 10 time. Yeah. So from like
diffusion models um they're definitely
like one of the architecture to consider
after a mixture of experts and
transformer-based architectures. Um
there field like is exploring different
types of models. there is state space
models, you know, all of them have
different like improvements on top of
the existing transformer decoder. I
would say right now they're still in
sort of like research. So in our like
inference API, we kind of try to put
models that are proven to be the best
and they are like robust for diffusion
models. I think we still trying to scale
like from research perspectives trying
to figure out what's the best recipe to
train them. But um I I know that this is
a very interesting research direction
that uh labs are looking at. I did see
an internal demo though that was insane
around diffusion models. So I like
diffusion models on Cerebras hardware is
going to be insane when it when it comes
out. Yes, that's not helpful to anyone
but you know I thought I'd throw that in
there. I can't even talk about it
because the the guy was like don't talk
about it now but I'm like but I'm being
very vague about it you know. So I have
a question related to what the previous
implement asked about fine-tuning model.
So say for example I have a new
architecture um which which has got
certain different layers which are not
there on not supported by cerus or does
not have those kernels defined what
would happen for those kind of situation
yeah that's a great question I think one
of our customers mistrol um is a great
example of this where they brought in a
custom architecture model um and they
were like hey we want to run this on
cerebrus and basically what it happens
is like a partnership and a
collaboration between their engineers
and our engineers to make sure that all
of the kernels are in place to support
the new architecture. So it's very
simple. It's just like all all our
hardware is if you think about it is a
bunch of memory and a bunch of compute
that are organized in a very efficient
way in a very like large surface area.
That's all it is. So we can technically
in theory support like a very diverse
set of models and architectures that may
not even exist yet. So it's all about
like creating that partnership and
figuring out like how do we support the
models that we don't yet support. So
that partnership is more about we define
those kernels. So that the architecture
there's also other quirks about models
like if there is like custom like RL or
something you know like it's all about
like making sure everything is supported
that you want to run in your model.
Thank you.
Okay. Um okay last call for questions.
Yeah. Um sorry I got here late but do
you think you'll ever do uh real time
APIs and sort of those other multimodal
models as well? So we actually support
uh we released our first multimodal API
uh not available publicly but through
the mistral app. So now if you use
mistrawl uh m large uh the the chat um
part many some of the imagebased queries
are running on hardware. So uh next
comes our cloud. So once we have it
running in one place, we assume we're
going to scale it into our public cloud.
So that will be coming pretty soon
actually to our service cloud for
multimodal around real time. We are
actually thinking about this. So like I
would love to learn more about your use
case. Um so yeah, real time is
definitely a very interesting I think
idea for the company because of the
speed of our inference. I think it'll be
great in like real-time use cases.
I think we have time for more questions.
Yeah, we do. We have like so much 40
minutes left. Yeah, maybe not all 45
minutes though, but you know what's up.
So I'm curious, has has there been
models engineered especially for
Cerebras hardware as in like you know
you have new types of capabilities and
I'm curious how good are people at
exploiting those capabilities, right?
Because people are taking existing
models and yes it's easy to you know
port them if you have the kernels but
what about stuff that you really would
um encourage people to try?
Wow, this is a very good question. Um,
so it really depends on what your use
case is. If you are a researcher who
wants to try a new architecture and
train it, I would say we have specific
um advantages for unstructured sparity
algorithms. So you can try that. Um I
don't think it's at the speed at any
other hardware. Um so if you try that on
GPU, it's going to be hard. Um that's
for pre-training side. for inference
side. Um I think for inference side not
yet because we released inference like
nine months ago. So it's a very very new
product and as we're working with
frontier model companies like mistrol
we're planning on having working with
them even more closely to design models
specifically to take advantage of not
only our current generation of chips but
our future generations of chips. You'll
have even more optimizations. But maybe
from the inference perspective, if you
have a very large model you want to
serve, then Cerebras is the best
position to do that. It's going to
scale, you know, multiple chips. You're
going to use multiple chips and you
won't have to like distribute the model
weights and wait, you know, uh for all
this like orchestration to work
together. Um so I would say like the
best use case here is like if you have a
very large model then use inference.
So I have two questions. First is you
know like What kind of model sizes can
be used simultaneously on a set instance
on one instance or like in a like when
I'm using it now I don't know how many
are currently so it's not a VM it's like
the number of systems but basically
there's no limit to the size of the
system because what we can do is we can
just infinitely add more chips like so
like go go go we can go from like as
small as like an 8 billion parameter
model and we can go all the way up to
like like Maverick is a recent model
that we were on boarded. We're planning
on supporting the bigger meta models,
you know. Um there's no limit because we
can just scale linearly. Our networking
architecture actually very simple just
but there's a cost associated with it of
course. So and
I wouldn't be able to partition a single
SOC or one service instance into Oh, we
can't we don't offer that right now in
our cloud basic. No, we basically handle
it. We handle the load. It's an we
currently only offer the service unless
it's like an on-rem client with just an
API. So, um we give you rate limits that
you can hit and we in the back end
provision the number of systems needed
to match your like workload. For the
public API that you everyone use today,
that's a shared pool where we set rate
limits for each user and then they can
consume until that rate limit.
Great question. Awesome.
Um, if there are no more questions, um,
uh, me and, uh, Daria will be up here.
Um, if you have more questions to come
up to us or if you're a startup looking
for inference, I'm the guy to talk to.
And if you also got 120, please bring
you getting 120 like get the proof and
then I'll get your email and give me
ideas for prizes and then we can go from
there. Thanks so much for coming
everyone. Thank you.
[Music]